(rolls tongue) Rossy, what's next?
All right. Up next, a writer in Vogue
recently explored this interesting question.
What if your friends don't like your partner?
Uh-oh.
Ooh.
For some, it could be a total deal breaker.
They'll just cut loose a lover
if they can't vibe with their friends,
but on the other end of this spectrum,
some say they actually prefer a healthy separation
between their partner and their friends,
'cause it helps 'em see all sides of themselves.
Here's the deal, right?
(laughs) What?
There is a choice you have to make.
If your friends tell you they don't like your partner
you have to think are they seeing something I'm not seeing?
Or is my relationship with them more important
than my relationship with my partner?
And I don't think there's a rule for everybody,
it's gotta be case by case.
What do you think?
(audience applauds)
I agree with that.
How many people here would be honest and just be like,
"I'm just not gelling with your partner."
How many people would actually be honest and say that?
(audience whoops)
I like it.
Not that many.
How many people would just quietly bite it
and kind of drift a little bit apart.
(applause ripples)
Show the hands,
If you don't mind. I love it.
Why were you giggling up there?
Yeah I mean, you have to be honest
and also to not ruin everything,
so it's difficult.
You ruined everything.
(all laugh)
Say that, what...?
I believe I heard a voice that said something about
"You ruined everything."
(audience laughs)
Wait, please, please.
What, what did he ruin?
Two days ago, I asked him to marry me
on the Brooklyn Bridge,
and he said to me, "Oh no, it's embarrassing, get up."
(audience exclaim)
Yes you did that.
No.
(audience jeer)
Okay, what does this have to do with a friend?
(audience laughs awkwardly)
Nothing.
Sorry, but I had to do this.
(audience laugh awkwardly)
Now what?
Because I wanted to do it myself.
Aw.
Later.
But not today.
(audience laughs)
No, we'll save it for an intimate moment.
Aw.
I'm getting the sense you don't like a crowd.
(audience laughs)
Right?
That was an emotional rollercoaster.
(audience applauds)
(bright music)